thank you
thank you Kareem so you're asking oil
companies to further lower gas prices
what makes you think that they are going
to listen to an Administration that is
ultimately trying to put them out of
business how how is the administration
trying to put them out of business well
they produce fossil fuels and this
President says he wants to end Foster
fuel
[Music]
thanks everybody
thank you
how you doing people I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's October 21st
in the year of 2022. it's a Friday I
hope you're ready for a weekend of fun
and pleasure and not so much politics
but we're gonna do a little bit of
politicking today as always we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube And blazetv
subscribe to all of our channels why not
like really think about it why not man
come on woman whatever you are get to it
come on subscribe all right do it uh we
got a Reuben report locals Community Q a
for you today but I do want to do two
stories before we get to the questions
uh because there's some interesting
things happening in the world there are
moments that are markers that make you
go oh maybe there really are trends that
most people can't quite see yet that are
important Trends uh one of them would be
a couple weeks ago it's Halsey gabbard
leaving the Democrat Party something the
mainstream media obviously not going to
pay too much attention to because they
run cover for the Democrats well how
Hollywood actor Mark Wahlberg and of
course you guys know Mark Wahlberg from
well he was in some of the Transformer
movies he was in Boogie Nights he was a
Calvin Klein model give me another Mark
Wahlberg movie come on give me something
what I said Transformers you're
obviously not paying attention you
Max Payne I don't think I saw that one
anyway he's an actor and uh he's leaving
Cali not only leaving Cali but he's
going to a place where he plans on
recreating Cali we'll get to that in a
little bit and then we showed you
yesterday just a little tiny bite of
this protest at aoc's rally in her home
District the people have absolutely had
it with her and she seems to be having
some sort of mental breakdown so we'll
get to that it's a lot of fun but let's
start with this Mark Wahlberg situation
so Mark Wahlberg who's A-list actor I'm
pretty sure he's got some Oscars uh he
also did that show on HBO he did
Entourage Entourage it was basically
based on his life well he is getting the
hell out of not only California but Los
Angeles specifically uh and he went on a
TV show to explain why oh that is the
biggest challenge right there Cheryl as
you know uh you know every free moment
that I have I'm at home you know I'm
literally I moved to Nevada where we're
after this gubernatorial election
hopefully you go to legislation and get
bill passed so we can get tax credits
for the state build a state-of-the-art
studio here and make this Hollywood 2.0
I want to be able to work from home I
moved to California many years ago to
pursue acting and I've only made a
couple of movies in the entire time that
I was there so to be able to give my
kids a better life and follow and pursue
their dreams whether it be my daughter
as an equestrian my son is a basketball
player my youngest son as a golfer you
know this made a lot more sense for us
um to go and hopefully build a studio as
well as a shoe factory and a factory for
municipal so we came here to uh you know
just kind of give ourselves a new look a
fresh start for the kids and there's
lots of opportunity here so I'm excited
I'm really excited about the future lots
of opportunity in Nevada not lots of
opportunity in Los Angeles I love how at
some point when you become so rich and
so influential when he's talking about
with his kids he's like yeah daughter is
going to be in Equestria and other
stuff's gonna be a basketball player
what was the other one like baseball
players I think it's just like
there's something to be said for success
and how that it can help the generation
behind you that's uh that's pretty sweet
um but in essence he's leaving and he
went on to continue to talk about it uh
because Los Angeles has become a dump
there are high taxes there are no
business opportunities that goes across
California it would be very hard not
only to open a studio which is what he
wants to do but imagine how would you
open a brick and mortar store if you
were just trying to open a sneaker store
if you were trying to open quite
literally anything you want to open a
barber shop how would you do that in Los
Angeles knowing that they could just
bust through your windows knowing that
you're going to be taxed High knowing
that they have all the regulations
related to who you're going to hire and
how much you have to pay them and all of
those things so you know when a guy he's
got to be worth can I get a net worth on
Mark Wahlberg I know those Network
things aren't totally uh you know
they're not totally on the money no it's
uh no pun intended but the guy's
probably worth 100 million bucks or
something like that and he's saying hey
the opportunities are not here for me
and my family I think that is a real
marker of what is going on with probably
a lot of Hollywood celebs a lot of
people getting out a lot of them are
going to Montana by the way I've been
just given some information he's worth
roughly this is just on an internet
search a cool 400 million dollars that's
more than I've got you guys no no you're
doing all right your boss is a good dude
anyway
I just thought that was interesting and
worth noting and then of course let's
take it from California to New York
because AOC was given a speech and she's
up for re-election right now she
actually has a contested election and
who knows maybe she won't be in our hair
much longer she is being protested at a
lot of her events lately and she seems
to be having some sort of nervous
breakdown foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so people are very frustrated with AOC I
think her own constituents are like wait
a minute wait a minute you know you were
supposed to help us here in this
District but you've been for all of
these big spending bills our economy is
not doing so great let's say across the
country but right here at home you're
into all of this woke stuff the woman
who was yelling there was in essence
saying hey there's only two genders male
and female AOC obviously is not all
about that
um and people are not happy that she's
been voting for all this money for
Ukraine and to escalate the war and the
rest of it and it's like she just kind
of sits there and she's mocking these
people and the rest of it and it's like
you know lady you have not felt any
adversity in your life I I am really
willing to put that out there any real
adversity she pretends she's a victim
right she's a progressive so you have to
be a victim but she has not faced any
adversity and certainly no adversity
when it comes to defending her ideas
right the the mainstream media
absolutely loves her she goes on CNN and
you know they they basically hand her
candy and just let her do her thing
that's in essence what they do
everywhere she gets on the cover of
Mademoiselle and Cosmopolitan and
everything else if you are a republican
that's new to the Congress that might be
thought of as kind of cool and new and
fun they treat you a little bit
differently much like Myra Flores the
Republican who won the Democrat seat for
100 years in the Border Town in Texas
and the New York Times basically said
she was the leader of the new Latina or
latinx far right that's what's going on
over there so when people come and
protest her now by the way I am not for
protesters interrupting speeches I have
been interrupted a gajillion times
there's many videos of it if you haven't
seen the video that I think it's got
millions and millions of views on
YouTube Google Dave Rubin University of
New Hampshire and watch these crazy
lunatic students coordinate screaming at
me and all of this stuff and bringing
noise makers and everything else I'm not
for that I like peaceful protest you
respect the speaker hopefully the
speaker will respect you it's why at
every event that I do I let people who
disagree with me come up first
um but putting putting aside the sort of
um the tactics of what these people are
doing I think people have had it and and
it is AOC herself who many times has
tweeted that the point of protest is to
make people uncomfortable get in their
face right what did Maxine Waters say
get them get in their face don't find
out where they're eating don't give them
a moment safety blah blah blah that is
what Democrat rhetoric has done and now
it's coming home the chickens are coming
home to roost lady and uh
I think I I think there's a chance we're
not going to have much much more with
her I think she could lose this election
I think anything is possible that is how
frustrated and sick of the woke people
are on that note let's get to the
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a uh
cecito says now that the boys are here
do you feel your life is more complete I
know Jordan talked about how a life is
more fulfilling with a family well
Jordan talking about that especially on
tour when I was with him
for that year and a half that as you
guys know that was one of the things
that really moved me on having kids and
the fact that David really wanted kids
and I had never put major thought into
it and I was so and I've been so focused
on my career for so long and then my
career started to really take off so I
thought okay maybe I can it's not that
I'm taking the my foot off the pedal
because I'm still as focused as I've
ever been here but maybe I can find a
little more room to expand my life in
different ways so uh to directly answer
your question yes my life feels denser I
guess is the way I would describe it you
know since you mentioned Jordan when I
was on tour with Jordan when he would
have a particularly good show and I
would always have the best seat in the
house right so I'm just sitting right
behind that curtain so I can not only
watch Jordan kind of from the side and
behind but I can see the thousands of
people and Jordan would walk off stage
we'd give him a high five or something
and I on a good night and they were
almost they were almost all great but on
just you know on a good night I would
say Jordan that show was dense it felt
thick it felt like you got to kind of
move through it and use some effort to
get through it as opposed to a thin show
you know like putting your finger
through a wet paper bag and that is sort
of how my life feels now it feels more
dense I I'm waking up in the middle of
the night sometimes there's feedings
there's diaper changes there's just
sitting moments of sitting with the baby
smiling knowing that the ideas that I'm
fighting for but I don't even mean the
political ideas like trying to be a good
person so that this uh kid I think of it
more in in terms of Luke because now
he's of almost 10 weeks so he's really
mature now uh sorry for Justin but Luke
as well it's like I want them to be able
to look at me and think there's a good
dude the guy that brought me into the
world one of the guys he's a pretty good
dude and he's mapped out a way that I
can be a good dude so yeah I would say
my life does feel uh
feels bigger and more important I
suppose uh snow says since Stacy Abrams
is saying abortion is a solution to
inflation what outrageous thing do you
think the Dems might say next so in case
you missed the show yesterday yeah this
is a thing it's an actual thing Stacey
Abrams went on television and basically
said forcing women to give birth in
essence is a drain on their pocketbook
and this is then causing inflation I
mean it's just so like unbelievably
insane what she's saying uh and it's
just so like are you truly a death cult
you people that you think somehow
aborting babies would be a solution to a
recession or or to make the inflation
less like it's it's gross what's next
with these people there's almost nothing
you can take off the table What would
what could they possibly do that you'd
be like boy I'm really surprised that
the Democrats did that there's almost
nothing they are endorsing drag shows
for kids this is out there all the time
now there are videos every day of drag
shows with these are grown adult men who
dress up like [ __ ] women and say
wildly inappropriate things and grab
their crotch and a whole bunch of other
stuff and somehow they've got them
reading children's book to kids I'm
fairly certain if you would have said to
somebody seven years ago do you know
that pretty much every Democrat would be
for drag shows for kids you'd be like
well you're nuts and now it's here so
there is almost nothing that they
wouldn't that would be too crazy for
them and that's why they must be stopped
and that's why this election is so
important Kathy says I see you're hiring
what are the most important qualities
you look for in a candidate what
impresses you the most in a potential
job candidate so yeah so right now we're
hiring a social media manager
and a graphics designer and and we're
things are good here so we're going to
keep hiring and keep bringing on more
people first off if you are a social
media manager if you are a graphics
designer if you got some of those skills
and you think you want to be part of the
team you can email us uh jobs at
reubenreport.com the way we do the
hiring here is I have my guys look
through the initial batch of resumes you
know we already got it we posted it on
on Instagram and in locals obviously in
a couple other places so we got a ton of
resumes already so I have my guys look
through the initial part make sure these
people are roughly qualified and then
once we have that sort of rough
qualification I have David and Daphne
and now Phoenix will all take a zoom
call with people just chat them up a
little bit kind of see how they if they
feel like they'd fit we're also deciding
does this person have to be here in
Miami or are we willing to do allow this
job to be remote my personal preferences
I like having people around but I'm
actually kind of open on on this one
because it's not somebody that has to
necessarily be in studio with me but
once they clear that round then they get
to me and when once they're with me
almost everyone that we've hired it's
like I just kind of want to feel your
Vibe I just want to feel like oh like
are you really passionate about this do
you strike me as somebody that's honest
and decent are you going to work hard
are you going to be reliable I've said
it a couple times but I think the best
thing that I've done in hiring is that
everyone that I have around me right now
nobody screws up anything
and if Connor you screw up something on
the show today that would be pretty
messed up
um nobody screws up anything like if I
ask for something to get done it gets
done nothing falls through the cracks
like we we are we are tight and airtight
if someone isn't feeling well or
someone's got to go somewhere for a
couple hours everyone picks up the slack
and we've built something really kind of
cohesive here so I want to make sure
whoever we bring in will fit within that
and I also wouldn't want them to be a
crazed woke nut job that's also
important uh USA says Dave did you know
you're running a cult my friend recently
accused me of being consumed by a cult
for stating opinions contradictory to
her own since you're my primary news
source I believe that makes you the cult
leader boy we should be drinking some
Kool-Aid today uh that's very that's
very exciting I'm a cult leader well
you know if it's a cult of Freedom then
I can get on board that cult yeah it's
so weird isn't it so weird you tell
people your basic opinions hey I don't
want the government involved in that
much hey I want to have choice for
people whether it's whether they're
going to get injected with things or
what school their kids go to hey I'd
like low taxes so people can figure out
what to do with their money as opposed
to a bureaucrat figured out you're in a
cult
it's like we ironically they're the ones
that have to be deprogrammed right we're
always talking about deprogramming cult
members well unfortunately the the
radical left the the walksters what what
is the driving force behind the Democrat
Democrat Party has become cult-like and
we got some deprogramming to do uh Glenn
says if Mr Putin gets to a point where
he feels he's winning and you are where
he feels winning in Ukraine won't be
possible without acceptable losses what
do you think are the chances of him
feeling he has no choice but to order
nukes on Ukraine and possibly other
countries and if he does give the order
do you think there's a chance it could
be disobeyed and what should the U.S
response be if the worst case happens uh
so first off I am going to interview I
think we're doing it later today so
it'll be up next week I'm going to
interview David sacks David sax is a
tech guy but he's become one of the most
outspoken critics of our policy related
to what's going on with Russia and
Ukraine and I think he's really hitting
the right notes and one of the driving
forces behind hey let's not get to World
War III on this so uh so hopefully
you'll get some insight from that
interview I would say to specifically
answer your questions
um well first on though would they not
listen to him part if he was to order
nukes I guess anything's possible but
pretty much the way Russia works like if
you're the one guy who's not following
orders you're most likely going to get
killed let's remember that when World
War II ended
and the Nazi regime collapsed and then
they had the Nuremberg trials and all
these other trials where they were
putting Nazis on trial and everyone said
well I was just following orders I was
just following orders so that sort of
pressure when you know you're doing
something wrong
um but you still do it it's a pressure
we all feel like look at two years of
covet look look the way man turned on
man husband turned on life like all of
it citizen turned on citizen
um do I think he would launch nukes I do
I think that if you pin this guy I've
been saying this from the beginning I
mean find whatever the first video I did
when this all started if you take a guy
who has nukes and even if he does a
bunch of bad stuff if you don't give him
some way to get out of that some way to
save face he knows about his regime will
collapse and then he will be out on the
streets where they will be hunting him
down remember those last days of Gaddafi
where literally people were hunting him
down he was in hiding and then finally
he died as a one of the guys chasing him
literally took a knife and jammed it up
his ass I am pretty sure that is not how
Putin wants to go down so would he he
has chosen this war against the West he
chose to invade a Sovereign Nation now
he had his reasons he believes that
Ukraine should be part of Mother Russia
he didn't like NATO getting closer to
his borders okay fine but at the end of
the day if he feels he is truly
threatened and they're going to have
regime change in in uh Russia which
Biden accidentally said very early on
and then he said we're having Armageddon
and he can't remain leader and all of
these crazy things it's like there I
don't think there is anything he would
not do in the name of self-preservation
which by the way is how most people
would behave
uh Zionist says I recently saw your
excellent interview with conservative
Israeli podcaster Gotti Taub I know
you're busy with the babies but when
will you come to Israel Shapiro has been
here quite a bit lately as has Jordan
Peterson please come before the boys Bar
Mitzvah well I've got about 13 years for
that roughly so I think I can get there
before then uh Ben actually just got
back I think he was in Israel for a
month and a half did a bunch of shows
there uh and Jordan and Ben actually
they went to Jerusalem together and
Jordan is taping a whole bunch of stuff
that's an extension of his biblical
Series so I'm actually very excited to
see that and I know that Jordans wanted
to go to Israel for a long long time we
were going to extend the tour and go
into Israel and then some of the Western
European countries and then just things
got a little bit messy and some health
stuff so it didn't happen but I would
love to get back to Israel I've been
invited several times to go to some
conferences I think in 2023 we're going
to do I mean we're already I know
we're already in the planning stages of
a European tour that will include Israel
so stay tuned and we'll probably have a
couple weeks on the road where we'll
talk to political leaders and I'll speak
at conferences and we'll do some some
comedy stuff and all that good stuff and
I'll eat hummus and baba ganoush and the
rest of it uh X house says hey Dave did
you play any on any sports teams growing
up and do you think you'll encourage
your sons to play on any sports teams
first off let me say
I told the guys this week I think one of
the reasons I've been in such a good
mood all week so you know I blew out my
ACL seven years ago playing basketball
and I just stopped playing my knee just
felt weak and I just stopped playing and
I so regret it because over the last
couple of weeks I met some guys down
here one of the guys has a full court at
his house and I'm playing every Tuesday
night a couple hours and I wear three
braces I wear a freaking ace bandage I
wear a sleeve and I wear like the metal
like Transformers Contraption on my knee
but I'm playing again and I'm playing
really well I'm hitting shots I still
got the finger roll like I can't do
everything I used to do but I still
regret such a mistake so if any of you
have a banged up something that you
should get that surgery on just go out
and get it
um I'm actually getting PRP on my knee
that's I think some of you know about
that that's when they literally take
your blood they spin it in a centrifuge
they inject I think it's the plasma of
your blood or the hemoglobin or
something they inject it back into you
and your own cells then can replicate
and and strengthen around whatever part
of your body you put it back and that's
what women do the women I guess men do
it too the vampire facial that the
Kardashians have done it's that sort of
thing so I'm getting that in my knee you
can't replicate my ACL but it can kind
of put it together anyway so basketball
is my main sport as you can tell
um and yes I can't we have a basketball
court here I cannot wait to get those
guys out there and uh Justin and Luke
and I'll you know teach them teach them
some moves and how to shoot and all that
stuff I I just can't wait for that
Sherry says what do you do when life is
too crazy or stressful or you find
yourself in a panic where you're Frozen
in the face of some problem you know
as you guys know my my general
temperament is kind of cool and I think
a lot of stress related things comes
from your temperament some people burn
real hot some people kind of cooler some
people in the middle uh but people that
run cool you still you're still going to
be faced with stress right like I've had
Financial stresses in my life I've had
familial stresses all the stuff that
everybody has
um one thing that I try to do if I'm
really stressed out I I really try first
off I try to stay away from my phone for
a little while because this thing which
was supposed to make us more social has
usually made us a far more anti-social
and anxiety written but if I'm stressed
or if I'm just trying to work through a
problem like if I just if there's just
something going on uh I find just a
simple walk I know that may sound corny
or
not that insightful but I find it I'll
just grab Clyde I usually do it with
Clyde and I'll just take a walk for a
while and you know it's funny I'm I
don't have a great sense of direction if
I don't have my phone I can still get
lost in my new neighborhood here like
it's kind of very a lot of trees
everywhere I sometimes I don't even know
where I'm going I'll just wander wander
wander that that kind of works for me I
think just taking a couple breaths like
little kind of simple simple things work
and uh yeah I'd be interested in hearing
how you guys deal with stress because uh
this is a it's like a bizarrely
stressful time even though there's so
much goodness and so many advancements
that we have but everyone feels
stressful because of the endless war
that's going on in our pocket uh hippie
says Dave I know how you feel about Star
Wars but I need to know how you feel
about the Lord of the Rings I have never
heard you mention it and I'm curious to
know if you're a fan
I I don't love Lord of the Rings I don't
you you love wait what's the thing with
you you love them or you hate them or
you think what is it you love it you so
Conor loves Lord of the Rings I hold him
in high regard when it comes to to
Comedy and movies where's you where do
you stand on Lord of the Rings Phoenix
not into it too very dismissive the way
you did that you don't care for it and
what do you like
you like oh you like The Hobbit not Lord
of the Rings oh
yeah whatever that's the same thing man
Hobbit you got a little guy with a hairy
foot and a bunch of a bunch of his
friends I just never loved the movies I
I don't know I'm also one of these
people where it's like to me it's like
you gotta pick Seinfeld or friends you
can't like both so I'm Seinfeld Star
Wars Lord of the Rings I'm Star Wars
despite what they've done you know what
I mean I can't ha I can't you know you
could say to me uh you like uh do you
like Journey or Chicago Journey
obviously
that's just how I operate so there we
are I don't I don't hate it I don't love
it I don't have cable anymore but I will
say back in the day when I had cable and
Lord of the Rings would be on TNT a lot
it was the type of thing that I could
just stop you know you're always when
you're just like flipping remember the
old days of flipping the channel I don't
do it anymore because I don't have cable
but back in the day for you kids you may
not know this we used to have cable
television that had uh commercials and
during the commercials you'd be flipping
to find something else because God
forbid you sit there and not actually
pay attention to something for a moment
so I'd be flipping if I found Lord of
the Rings it was one of the things I
could stop on also Shawshank shawshank's
always on and you always stop on it
Japanese that's funny says with two
daddies with the same name what will
your boy boys call each of you so right
now
although the kids are not talking yet
but I have a feeling Justin's going to
be an early talker because he's making
all sorts of crazy sounds already uh I'm
going to be dad and David will be Daddy
I was also we had many discussions about
it and we'll see I mean if they start
calling us different things or opposite
things whatever we'll we'll figure it
out
um I could also go down as Big Daddy
because blanche's father in The Golden
Girls was Big Daddy and what I've been
doing my Georgian Accent on the show
it's based a little bit on Big Daddy I
do declare
um I could also could have also been
Pops I was really okay with being pops
because Pops to me is the old guy at the
basketball court and then there's like
nine kids playing and they need one guy
and then pops is sitting there under the
tree maybe drinking a lemonade and then
they're like yo Pops you want to play
and then pops gets out there and Pops
can still do some stuff and then pops
tells the stories of you know that kids
love to hear about old basketball
players that they've never heard of kids
love hearing that sort of thing so I
could have been pops but I was told Pops
too old sounds too old Michelle says
Dave my third grade catechism class
talked about places on Earth where we
are in awe Yellowstone Guadalajara
Colorado and about taking a moment to
say thanks where was the last place you
went that left you in awe and wonder
this one I know for sure a few times
that we've gone off the grid we have
been fortunate enough to go to Bora Bora
Bora Bora is in French Polynesia it's
these little Islands you've all seen
pictures of them that there's basically
nothing there but those Huts over the
water it's not cheap like it's worth
saving up and trying to get there you
most likely depending on where you're
coming from have to take several flights
and POS and definitely boat rides as
well like it's an operation to get there
but when you are sitting in one of these
units above the water and you can see
all the fish these gorgeous huge
extraordinary fish and sharks sometimes
right below you because some of the some
of the units have glass bottom floors
and when you wake up
and you know you've got just glass in
front of you and you open those doors
and you're on your porch
and you got a coffee maker in your room
and you're having coffee just laying
there
and you might be naked I'm just saying
and you're just laying there and all you
see is the Horizon you just see water
forever and then at the edge of the
water you see the sky and it is so
peaceful it is so wonderful
um I miss it I miss it obviously we
didn't do it this August we had we had a
baby but I do hope I can get there again
at some point like it is just so magical
like you feel like you feel like you're
at the edge of the universe you know
like what is beyond that what is beyond
that over there it's just it's just
awesome love says now that Rumble has
gone public do you think Joe Rogan would
consider switching his program to rumble
please make him a deal make him a deal
he can't refuse well as you guys know I
was it was my idea to offer him 100 Mil
I wrote the the press release to or the
the request that went to him
um and uh and he did not take it he was
he's still under a deal with Spotify you
can't just walk and the Spotify deal I'm
told is worth probably two or three
hundred million when you add up a whole
bunch of things look rumble's in the
game now we are a public company we got
plenty of cash we'd love to have Joe we
would not have any of his episodes
censored you know Spotify still has I
think it's about 100 episodes of his
show that are censored not on Spotify he
could bring them all to rumble uh I
think we just have to keep building good
things you know I am just a firm
believer in that if you build it they
will come and if you just do good work
you build good things and then you show
people hey we have a set of principles
we got a good product we're decent
people come on down I think people will
will come so uh yeah if I if I connect
with Joe again I'm happy to make the
offer in person and uh and we shall see
I think it would be a wise move for him
I I don't think Although our podcast is
also on Spotify like Spotify has made it
clear that free speech is not the the
the prime driver of what they do Rumble
as a company free speech is the thing
you are allowed to come on Rumble and
make videos about how you don't like
Dave Rubin and say all sorts of mean
things about me or whatever you want to
do uh again if you break the laws of the
United States that you've got a much
bigger problem than us but beyond that
we are we are here to be a neutral
platform which I think is exactly what
everybody wants uh Eliza says do you
think that the trend of Democrats
refusing to debate their Republican
opponents was a planned strategic move
by the Democrat Party power players to
avoid having to address their horrible
record on every issue that's a good
question because is it coming top down
or bottom up so the main example of what
you're talking about is that Katie Hobbs
in Arizona is refusing to debate Carrie
Lake and Carrie Lake really I think if
anyone has become the All-Star the
Superstar politically during this
election season I think it's her more
than anyone else she's hitting the
mainstream media she used to be a
journalist she's fact-based she's
obviously very pretty she is a great TV
presence she gets it she gets it and
she's there and she's fighting she's
challenging her to to debates and Katie
Hobbs is hiding Katie hobb's like well
we got 30 days left and I got some
fundraisers and uh and she's just got
nothing left to me
if a major political party says hey
you're our guy or you're our gal meaning
a Republican party says it or a Democrat
uh says you should be tied into debating
you cannot duck a debate at that point
right like it just should not be allowed
however the system has to operate to
make that so uh how embarrassing like
how dare Katie Hobbs if you think about
it I am here to run this state that's
what I would like to do you citizens I
would like you to vote for me so I can
run this state so I can figure out I can
be the chief executive and figure out
the best way for Arizona to go forward
but I won't ask or answer any questions
that my opponent gives me and I won't
just stand there and uh and honestly
combat this person's ideas I just won't
do that but you should just trust that
I'm going to do the right thing when I'm
in power it's it's uh it's really
embarrassing actually as to whether it's
coming from her specifically or her
campaign or the top down it might be a
little bit of both it might depend on
the race it might depend on the state I
I don't know exactly but I should not
surprise any of us and I suspect it will
be a trend that will continue which by
the way was it was a clever move in them
always calling us all racists and Nazis
because if there was a racist and a Nazi
would you debate them and that's kind of
what she's trying to say here I don't
have to debate that person that person's
an election denying crazy white
supremacists blah blah blah
Maybe not maybe not Lynn says since the
CDC is going to add covet vacs to the
list of required childhood shots will
Florida Buck the trend and refuse yes I
or I saw a video uh this morning you
know it can relay in a little bit of it
all right we're going to lay in a little
bit of it right now there's been a lot
of questions uh to our office about the
CDC protected potentially adding covid
vaccine to the childhood immunization
schedule and I know a lot of parents are
concerned about that because if that's
on the immunization schedule the fear is
that schools could potentially mandate
your child to get a coveted shot even if
that's not something that you want to do
so I just want to let everyone be clear
you know as long as I'm around and as
long as I'm kicking and screaming uh
there will be no covid shot mandates for
your kids that is your decision
foreign
does that make me proud to be a
Floridian or what God bless Ron DeSantis
uh it is just absolutely fantastic what
he is doing here and if that means we
need to see more and more of a
separation of red State and blue State
and these the states just have to go
their separate ways I am actually
completely fine with that the idea that
you would trust the CDC at this point to
inject things into your children as a
new father is so profoundly uh it's just
off the charts for me it is off the
charts what are you going to do you're
going to come get me no I live I live in
the Free State of Florida I make I make
decisions for myself and my family very
proud to be a Floridian in case you
didn't know that oh and I'll be going to
the uh the Florida debate uh in a couple
days there is one gubernatorial debate
it is Ron DeSantis versus Charlie Crist
and it's going to be a bloodbath into
Santa's favor uh so I will be there I'll
see if I can do some live streaming and
certainly we'll take some pictures and
videos and that sort of stuff uh
Elizabeth says at the end of your career
which is hopefully a long time from now
because you're awesome what do you hope
you'll be remembered for
I think it would be something like he
tried he tried to bring a little bit of
Sanity in a very insane world like as
everyone went nuts and everybody just
made politics everything and people
tried to destroy each other and
everything else for whatever mistakes he
made or predictions he made that were
wrong or whatever that he tried to tell
people that there are good ideas out
there and he tried to shine some light
on those good ideas and help people
understand you don't have to just rely
on on other people and governments for
help you have something within you that
is special and worthwhile and I think my
life is an example of it I just started
saying what I thought and the next thing
you know I've I have virtually
everything I want in my life like
there's something there as I discussed
with Bill Maher like that's the universe
the universe is out there and you can
grab some pieces of it and put together
something that is pretty close to what
you want in life I really believe that
every single one of you watching this
there's something you want to do in your
life whatever that means does it mean
you want to be a great parent does it
mean you want to be a tech entrepreneur
does it mean you want to be a soccer
player well you know what if let's say
whatever you want it to be if you want
to be a great basketball player I would
love to be in the NBA I don't really
care about the NBA anymore but I would
have loved to have been a professional
basketball player like that was not in
the cards but I still love playing
basketball you've got to just find some
stuff you like and go for it go for it
and then you start building a family in
a community around you and you can
change the world I really really really
believe that you can ladies and
gentlemen I hope you have a great
weekend if you have not subscribed
already please do at rumble.com Ruben
report and you can always join us for
live chat and much more at
reubenreport.locals.com and we leave you
with uh I haven't said anything about oh
no I did say something about Cali today
I didn't put any cash in the jar because
I've ran out of cash I got I got this
whole thing but I ran out of cash so we
got to get some more cash but we leave
you with the cold clothes this is back
in 2000 7 when evil soulless lizard
person who at the time was the mayor of
San Francisco Gavin Newsom had to
apologize for an affair he was having
with his secretary who was also the wife
of his Deputy Chief of Staff who he
supposedly was friends with anyway he's
a horrible person have a nice weekend
thank you all for coming Aaron's short
notice I want to make it clear that
everything you've heard and read is true
and I am deeply sorry
about that I've heard someone I care
deeply about Alex Turk his friends and
family
and that is something that I have to
live with and something that I am deeply
sorry for
I
I'm also sorry that I've let the people
of San Francisco down
they expect a lot of their mayor and my
personal
lapse of judgment aside I am committed
to restoring their trust and confidence
and will work very hard in the upcoming
months to make sure that the business of
running the city is framed appropriately
I also want to extend a personal apology
to everyone in our Administration to my
staff that I just met with to my friends
and my family members I am deeply sorry